[Musique]
c'est une visite que nous voulions faire
depuis très longtemps la commission des
affaires économiques tant à la fois le
sujet du nucléaire un sujet de
préoccupation très fort dans notre
commission et également parce que
flamanville connaît effectivement des
retards et des surcoûts et que nous
voulions apprécier si l'arrivée de
flamanville allait effectivement être
opérante à la fin de l'année prochaine
il me semble important c'est de parler
déjà des travaux de remise à niveau des
soudures de leclerc dont on a beaucoup
parlé donc aujourd'hui ce chantier
avance très bien avec plus de 86% des
soudures qui devait être remise à niveau
des travaux ont commencé sur ses
soudures là et 66% de ses soudures sont
maintenant fini est bonne donc on a bien
avancé
[Musique]
dur à réparer et plusieurs mètres à
l'intérieur donc les robots qui ont été
qualifiés
un marche forcée on passait à
l'intérieur cette partie là pour pouvoir
faire des opérations de découpe d'un
rasage des opérations de soudage de
contrôle etc et donc maintenant les
dernières étapes là dessus ça doit être
de finir les soudures qui sont de
l'autre côté du bâtiment pour ensuite
après à dire monte l'autre portion
depuis opté pour pouvoir la soude et de
part et d'autre et firmi les revêtements
circuit
[Musique]
ce que nous avons vu à flamanville ici
et notamment sur le dr c'est qu'un état
d'avancement vraiment satisfaisant avec
de nombreux problèmes techniques qui
désormais sont en passe totalement
d'être d'être comblé d'être résolue
alors il reste les validations qui sont
très très importante mais il nous semble
que le projet aujourd'hui est en très
bonne voie
notre ambition c'est de finir ses
travaux de soudage à 100% pour la fin de
l'année 2022 devenir ensuite à tester
l'ensemble de l'installation au premier
trimestre 2011 porte pour un chargement
du combustible donc au deuxième
trimestre 2003
[Musique]